-Our next guest is
an Emmy Award-winning acto
you know from his work
on "Will & Grace"
and "American Horror Story."
He stars in "Call Me Kat," which
airs Thursday nights on Fox.
Please welcome to the show
Leslie Jordan.
How are you, Leslie?
-I'm good!
Thank you for having me.
-You know, I hope I'm righ
in saying this.
It seems like a very good time
to be Leslie Jordan.
-Well, I don't know.
Give me a good pandemic,
and I seem to flourish,
which is an awful thing to say
But I just have done so well
during this time
that it's amazing
what I've accomplished.
-One of the things you did
was you found your way
onto Instagram,
and you provided a lot of jo
and comfort to people
who were looking for it
during this
really troubling time.
-And you know, I really didn't
set out to do that.
I was stuck in Tennessee
at my mom's house --
my mama, my sweet mama --
and I was going crazy.
And I had -- I had not bee
on Instagram for a while.
I mean, about a year --
about two years ago,
I was on a TV show called
"The Cool Kids,"
and the head of publicity
at the time would tell me,
"Post, you know, that funn
thing you said, post this.
And I thought, I didn't know
what she was talking about
I really didn't.
I thought maybe she meant
post-its,
those little yellow things
[ Both laugh ]
And so, she said, "No, you nee
to put that on Instagram."
And then she looked at me,
and she said,
"You don't have an Instagram
account, do you?"
I said, "No, ma'am, I don't.
And so they opened me one,
and within a week,
I had 20,000 followers,
and I couldn't shut up about it.
I said, "Can you believe?"
They said, "That's nothing
compared to what you can have.
And then, Megan Mullally
from "Will & Grace" posted -
reposted something of mine
I jumped to 80,000 followers
and i couldn't believe it.
And then when the --
when the stay-at-home orders
happened and I didn't
have anything to do,
I was in Tennessee,
I started posting twice a day,
just silliness,
just silly stuff.
And my friend called
from California.
He said, "You've gone viral.
I said, "No, honey,
I'm in Tennessee with my mama.
I'm fine.
I don't have COVID."
He said, "No! You've gone vira
on the Internet."
And now, here we go.
I don't know, 5.6 million.
I have no idea.
I just, you know --
-That's fantastic.
It's well-deserved.
You mentioned being in Tennessee
with your mom
and your twin sisters, as well
correct?
-Yes. I have
identical twin sisters
who are 22 months
younger than me.
And they live with mom.
And it's like
a dog and pony show.
I bought them
a really pretty house,
the best thing
I ever did as an adult.
Looks like Laura Ashley
threw up in there.
[ Laughter ]
But it's just precious.
And I get back there quite a bit
to see mama and them,
as we say in the South.
[ Laughter ]
-Are they happy to see you
when you come home?
-Oh, they are.
You know what?
When we were growing up, m
sisters got all the attention.
I think
that's what's wrong with me.
[ Both laugh ]
Because identical twins
and mother back then, you know
in the '50s and '60s,
would put them in little outfits
that matched,
and people would
"Ooh" and "Ahh,"
and I'd be over there pullin
out my pee-pee
and turning cartwheels,
whatever I could think of!
"Somebody, please,
look at me, look at me!"
So...
-Now, Leslie,
you first made your way --
was it directly from Tennessee
to Los Angeles in the '80s
-I did.
I took a Greyhound bus.
I had -- It was 1982.
My mother sewed $1,200
that I had saved waiting table
into my underpants.
And I got --
I got off at the corner
of De Longpre and Vine,
which is a block below
Hollywood and Vine,
which is the story of my lif
and my career, one block below
[ Laughter ]
But -- And I just --
You know, I don't know.
I don't know how it happened
It just happened.
You know, I just hit town
at a time when there was a lad
named Clara Peller
out of Chicago
on a Wendy's commercial.
She said, "Where's the beef?
And all of a sudden,
they all wanted,
you know, character actors
and I started doing commercial
and this and that.
And then I got
on "Murphy Brown,"
and I'll give you my whole
résumé, if you want me to,
if you ask.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, are you happy to be bac
on a sitcom now?
-This one, you know,
I told Mayim Bialik
when I first started
working on the show,
I said, "You know, this is
the best show I've been on."
She said, "Oh."
I said, "No, I'm having
more fun right now."
I don't know if it's 'caus
I'm 65 and I've done it all,
you know, and now I'm just ready
to have a good time,
but it's so beautifully written.
Darlene Hunt, that created it,
I play a character
that's so close to me,
I'm not even really acting
I thought the other day,
"Why is this so easy?"
I thought,
"'Cause you're just out there,
you know, being yourself."
And we have such a great cast,
and we have a really,
really good time.
And I think it comes through
I hope it just runs forever.
-Another exciting thing
you have coming up is,
you're writing a book of essays.
This won't be
your first book, though.
How did the previous efforts go?
-Well, my last book was called
"My Trip Down the Pink Carpet,
and I had some axes to grind
[ Laughter ]
You know, I was raised
in the Baptist church,
and I've been baptized 14 times.
Every time
the preacher would say,
"Would the live sinner
come forward?" I'd go forward.
He said, "I believe I baptized
you this summer."
I said,
"Well, I don't think it took."
[ Laughter ]
I had some axes to grind.
So, I wrote --
This time, I just thought,
"I'm gonna just sit down
and write some funny stories
about little lessons
I've learned along the way."
And I'm so tickled with the wa
it turned out,
and the publishers
are over the moon with it.
I think it's gonna come ou
on Mother's Day,
which is a wonderful tribute
to my mother.
So, it's a good time
to be Leslie Jordan.
It's just a good time.
-You also --
You used to do one-man shows
You would do a fair amount
a year.
-Ooh!
I'd do 45 venues a year.
I trotted from one end
of this country to the other
I would tell,
you know, funny stories.
And I was the only one
really doing what I was doin
at the time,
because what I would do is
I would go to gay bars,
usually, and tell them,
"Listen, you take the --
you take the bar.
I'll get them all in here,
and I'll take the gate.
We'll charge them 20 bucks."
We'd do some horse trading
and I'd walk away
with $4,000, $5,000 in a night
And so, I just went, you know,
gay bar to gay bar to gay ba
doing that for years.
Oh, gosh.
I don't have to do that anymore.
I got a few dollars
in the bank now.
I don't have to do that.
-Well, I'm sorry I missed
my opportunity to see it.
It must've been something, but I
can't wait to read your book
And, Leslie,
please do come back soon.
This has been
an absolute delight.
-I would love to.
Thank you so much for having me.